[Music]
when I was young I remember listening to
my elders telling me that knowledge his
power learn my child they used to say no
let's make you smart and smart people
have a chance to thrive in this world to
inhabit their words sounded vague to my
color ears what is the knowledge they're
referring to knowledge of mathematics
knowledge of physics knowledge of
languages Street knowledge knowledge of
Human Relationships unable to properly
fathom their ambiguous advice I grew up
to become a generalist there is a person
with a wide array of useful knowledge I
started to think in systems and this
mode of cognition led me to deeper
States Of Consciousness that challenged
the way I interpret did the world I
became more aware of my own existence my
own limitations and my own potential and
that's when it dawned on me the elders
were right but not right enough and the
request for knowledge they ignored the
true essence of what knowledge his
purpose actually is knowledge is indeed
power but the path from knowledge to
power is not immediate there are stages
one needs to follow and they could be
summarized in the following sequence
knowledge awareness control Power
knowledge breeds awareness that is the
consumption of knowledge leads to a
collection of wisdom nuggets that when
properly construed can raise awareness
awareness is the ability of the
individual to make sense of oneself and
consequently of the world around them
once this process manifests itself one
is able to transition from a state of
cluelessness and incompetence to a state
of control and power when I say power I
don't mean power power over others but
power over the things you can control
and you can control only what you
understand what you are aware of so the
imperative word here is not knowledge
but awareness awareness is power and
freedom for awareness has always been
the key to a life defined by Clarity
intent and cohesion there is a path that
one needs to follow in order to properly
grasp what awareness really is and path
I Endeavor to lay out today
when you're younger the world around you
feels overwhelmingly complex you're
thrown in this world with no experience
and sometimes with no support you feel
clueless and incompetent empirical
investigation has led me to believe that
the reason for this is twofold and has
little to do with the intelligence two
major forces that enforce this
circumstance so to speak are the
education system and the development of
the frontal cortex let me elaborate a
brief history of how modern education
came about reveals that from the 17th
century onward the purpose of school was
to create better workers not better
humans employers have viewed school as a
means to teach future employees the
rules of punctuality following
directions tolerance for long hours of
tedious work and the minimal ability to
read and write on top of that as Nations
became more centralized and national
leaders saw a great chance in schooling
to lay the foundations for the
facilitation of future Patriots and
soldiers in essence the school was not a
place where children could enjoy
holistic education and develop a healthy
personality it was more like a prison
where they would eventually lose their
identity creativity and motivation with
regards to the frontal cortex prolific
biologist Robert sapolsky revealed in
one of his lectures something
groundbreaking the frontal cortex is the
last part of the brain to fully develop
your frontal cortex is not fully
developed until around age 25 that is
astonishing that explains an awful lot
of behavior in freshman dorms that
explains all sorts of things the frontal
cortex takes forever to develop
and thus childhood is filled with a
frontal cortex that doesn't work very
well yet what does the frontal cortex do
all sorts of complicated things
regulating executive behaviors and
strategizing on the very simplest level
what is the frontal cortex do it makes
you do the harder thing when it's the
right thing to do
this is an astonishing finding and
reveals two things number one that
frontal cortex is predominantly sculpted
by environment and is listed constrained
by genes which apparently suggests that
it is quite malleable and number two
that young people don't have the
capacity to totally benefit from most of
its uses until their mid-20s if we take
into account these two factors and
combine them with the proclivity of
humans to usually choose the path of
least resistance when it comes to action
taking we find ourselves in a very
unfavorable situation we end up with a
huge amount of the population feeling
not only clueless about who they are but
also lacking the necessary context that
would Empower them to discover their
individual Constitution nonetheless this
stage is possible to overcome firstly if
the individual understands his or her
limitations
secondly by methodically accruing
knowledge relevant to the alleviation of
these limitations patience is key here
and when coupled with an incessant
tendency to question conventional wisdom
it can produce extremely interesting
outcomes
[Music]
the famous Maxim know thyself has been
echoing throughout history since its
first usage by Plato in his dialogues
there are at least six instances during
which Plato employs the maxim and in
every one of them he does so in order to
stress out the importance of
self-discovery and the development of
the individual although the context in
each instance is different the rationale
Remains the Same a self-aware individual
is a conscious individual individuals
who can't partake in the process of
self-exploration will systematically
fall victim to their own lack of
awareness and the consequences that such
a state causes some of the consequences
include confusion due to a lack of
intent behind decision making
frustration due to a lack of
understanding why certain calamities
occur in their lives hyperbolic
emotional reactions when certain needs
remain unmet manipulation by external
agents that will try to present
themselves as saviors and take advantage
of the predicament the individual faces
essentially a lack of self-awareness is
the main source of dogmatism in society
today humans will always seek her to
belong and this lasts for tribalism can
often yield friction within Society most
people who cling to certain usually
extreme ideologies do so because they
haven't sorted themselves out the
absence of a strong individual identity
destabilizes the substrate of their
being and they're constantly in the look
for more stable worlds to grab onto
these stable worlds can often be
dogmatic worlds that reject certain
aspects of reality in an attempt to deal
successfully with its innately chaotic
nature religions political movements
Cults extremist groups or all in that
category and are there to remind us what
a lack of self-awareness can and gender
in a way people who belong in these
groups are manifestations of a person's
inability to face the concept of the
Shadow as Carl Jung put it the shadow is
the unknown Dark Side of our personality
dark because it is very obscure and also
because we need to dig very deep within
our psyche in order to discover it it is
a conglomeration of all of our fears
desires and impulses like sexual last
power striving selfishness greed Envy
anger or rage and it operates in a
subconscious level a person can never
reach the state of self-actualization if
they haven't managed to face the shadow
until they can understand it deal with
it and eventually assimilate it plate
also pointed out that understanding
thyself would also result to a greater
understanding of the nature of Being
Human namely understanding oneself would
also enable a person to form an
understanding of others as a result in
order to understand yourself first you
need to understand your past and how
your past affects your present and your
future the operative word here is past
but I use it to allude to both our past
as individuals but also to our past as
species from an individual's perspective
psychoanalysis is the most pertinent
tool one can use to explore certain
aspects of their personality major
events in our past have played the
critical role in shaping who you are
today going back to those events facing
them and creating associations with
current ones can significantly raise
self-understanding from a species
perspective humans are a work of
evolution in progress and our current
state can't be fathomed if we don't
examine closely the practices and habits
of our ancestors and draw parallels to
current behavioral patterns
[Music]
the complexity of our social fabric is
an undeniable reality we are
idiosyncratic creatures that perpetually
try to balance between individuality and
togetherness usually we fail
dramatically in that attempt but it
doesn't always need to be this way the
way a person forms their understanding
of social dynamics is fostered during
childhood and Depends largely on the way
the upbringing functions within the
household a child can get a glimpse of
how real Society operates and adopts
certain characteristics that will help
them transition smoothly from the
microcosm of their family to the
Wilderness of the real world they're in
the child develops an intuitive ability
to interact and cooperate with others
hence most people make adjustments about
others based on intuition intuition is
indeed a powerful skill but alone is not
enough it can offer a rough
understanding ending of social patterns
but if you want to understand the
mechanics deeply you need to enhance
your social skills repertoire in that
respect I'm going to briefly touch upon
three major areas one needs to be aware
of
our perception is usually confined
within the limits that our ego dictates
we are raised to think individually and
not see logistically that process
seriously hinders our capacity to
understand and cooperate with fellow
humans and our ability to form mutually
beneficial connections suffers
dramatically empathy is the ability to
understand and share the feelings of
another it is a process that leads to a
complete re-engineering of a person's
worldview since it can offer them a
completely new perspective on life
cultivating empathy is the first step
into unweaving the mysterious
entanglement that encompasses our social
life
humans are evolved primates with an
extremely sophisticated set of cognitive
tools the way however our social
structures are formed rely more on power
rather than sophistication for years we
have attempted to evolve our societies
from hierarchies to more egalitarian
systems for years we have failed to do
so this reality is a result of an
Eclectic amalgamation of reasons such as
cultural differences environmental
influences intelligence tribalism
religion and nepotism and the general
lack of affinity towards forming
Collective views it seems that on
average our primitive mind tends to
dominate our more rational one and the
future doesn't look much promising in
that respect one needs to be aware of
these truths and to exercise his or her
capacity to deal with them consistently
in order to stay safe and competent in
our power oriented environment
the reason our species thrived and
managed to reach this prosperous time in
history is predicated upon our ability
to cooperate and establish laws that
will allow stability to Prevail within
our societies these laws would have
never existed in the first place if it
weren't for the happiness of certain
individuals to influence and persuade
others to follow their ideas and causes
influence and persuasion are two of the
most ancient human arts and have shaped
our social makeup like no others yet not
so many seem to pay close attention to
them a heightened awareness cannot
manifest itself with the absence of
basic knowledge and influence and
persuasion not only does this knowledge
allow the individual to see behind the
scenes of reality but it also offers
more clarity when dealing with the
complexity of human nature such
knowledge shouldn't be clouded by
neglect
foreign
[Music]
process one will inevitably reach a
point where reality will become very
different than before the interpretation
of patterns both within oneself and
within others can result in an over
analytical mode of thinking and this
over analysis can more often than not be
too much to handle people transform from
random entities that interact with you
in an aimless fashion into intricate
beings that reveal all their intentions
and hidden agendas just by the way they
move talk and operate reality gets
examined to the point of Madness this
idea gained instant currency when I
stumbled upon the writings of the
infamous novelist
this prodigious figure showcased his
quintessential mind when he introduced
us to a writing style so dense and
tireless that feels like the ideal
analogy to an over-analytical
interpretation of the world here is a
passage from the book War and war that
illuminates what reality examined to the
point of Madness freeze like because he
didn't feel like going home to an empty
apartment on his birthday and it really
was extremely sudden the way it struck
him that good Heavens he understood
nothing nothing at all about anything
for Christ's sake nothing at all about
the world which was a most terrifying
realization he said especially in the
way it came to him in all its banality
vulgarity at a sickeningly ridiculous
level but this was the point he said the
way that he at the age of 44 had become
aware of how utterly stupid he seemed to
himself how empty how utterly
blockheaded he had been in his
understanding of the world these last 44
years for materialized by the river he
had not only misunderstood it but had
not understood anything about anything I
have been there many times I assume that
most of you have been there too your
mind is trying to navigate your thoughts
through this Labyrinth of Madness and
you feel hopeless you are afraid you'll
go crazy humans are not designed for
this we progressed from a state of
Simplicity to a state of Randomness and
complexity quite abruptly technology
allowed us to connect with each other
and stretch our cognitive limits in
unprecedented ways we thought that we
would improve every aspect of our
experience but in reality we started
then to lose our minds once you
understand this don't be hard on
yourself don't fight it don't get mad
don't despair don't worry about feeling
uncomfortable instead understand that
feeling uncomfortable should be viewed
as a virtue not a hindrance the key here
is to realize that necessity of this
stage view it the same way you view
adversity and growth since adversity is
a necessary ingredient of growth allow
it to train you and strengthen your
mental resilience for it probably
constitutes the most imperative stepping
stone to reaching what one so
desperately desires extreme
self-awareness and extreme
self-ownership
[Music]
chaos Randomness entropy and Serendipity
are all elements of disorder that engulf
The Human Experience when dealing with
them people can be easily categorized
into two groups the ones that Despair
and the ones that accept the first group
will constantly find reasons to complain
lament and allow reality to devastate
them the second group will accept
reality as it is understand what they
can control and eventually come up with
a strategy human nature is what it is
one cannot change the world as a whole
but one can definitely change his or her
world that's the power of self-awareness
and that's what the final stage of
awareness Mastery so to speak feels like
during that stage one should consider
seriously the Triad of pragmatism
anti-fragility and search for meaning
pragmatism allows us to see and speak
the truth we stop being delusional and
we adopt a proactive stance towards
challenging situations the absurdity of
this world can be dealt with only when
we stop idealizing circumstances and
instead adapt to the requirements of
every circumstance anti-fragility is the
word that was missing from our
vocabulary since the closest we could
get in describing things that withstand
pressure is robustness
introduced us to the term anti-fragile
our whole experience shifted gears we
didn't have to accept robustness as our
ultimate option and we managed to move
beyond that to a state that actually
gains from disorder finally a lack of
meaning can lead to nihilism and
although nihilism can be useful in
certain cases excessive adherence to it
can lead to chaos meaning bring
structure and structure is the only
antidote to the deleterious effect of
chaos when I discovered the five stages
to awareness it felt like a momentary
Vision one of profound effects and one
to which my first response was to run
off to tell somebody about it this video
is perhaps a microcosm of my pursuit of
self-awareness it represents the vital
need to confess my own unique experience
and share it in knowledge immediacy with
you hope you enjoyed it
thank you
[Music]